I believe Manuel Peterson is just  winning this game now  black should claim they must have made  50 moves  Checkmate okay last chance to check last  chance to claim he resigns why don't you  claim  you gotta claim  you have to claim yeah  wow this is shocking  woof  but yeah a lot of action we still don't  know who the player on the black side  was that's such a typical story no he  defends confidently and well for  thoroughly moves then you lose focus for  a second looks like white pizzas are in  random squares and all of a sudden you  end up in one of these losing positions  but I should really have claimed that's  maybe lack of experience playing these  events yeah too much too much  sportsmanship yeah that he also cared  about designing instead of just trying  his luck yeah that's because it it did  feel like there were a bunch of moves  there maybe there were more than 50.  sure